[Music]
do you think it's harder to perform in
rapid and blitz or in classical I think
kind of the same since I have prayed
rapping in plate and also catechol in
the previous tournament my reloads will
it be similar in this kind of is two
kind of tournaments for some players
playing bits and wrap it is more natural
I would say that's my case it's it's
different yeah I think it depends on
each player at least lately I've been
feeling more comfortable in in classical
there's more pressure in classical but
rapping blitz has its own challenges one
of which is that there's so many games
in today and so if you go on a losing
streak it's hard to recover from that
but if you're on a winning streak I mean
it's great sometimes you've seen loosing
players collect like you know seven wins
in a row or finish a day with like eight
out of nine or something
so yeah there's a lot of opportunity to
run away with the tournament but it's
also very easy to get demoralized and
you know I start losing game up to the
end it's happened to me for sure I'm
sure it's happened to pretty much every
player well for me it's more part in the
classical event because in repertory
this much it's much simpler it depends
on your form and if you are on a good
form you can fight for for the first
place and in classical also if you are
in good form you can try to fight but
it's still much more difficult I
remember one time I was number two in
the bridge and after one month service
from number 14 in the world it's I play
just three tournaments very bad and I
was trying the yellow or more than 200 I
mean it's changed sometimes you play
well sometimes but at Costco more
important well when you're playing rapid
game
opposed to a classical game it's easier
to forget your failures because you're
going to make mistakes anyway when you
make them in a rapid or avoids game you
get a chance to play the next game and
show that you've learned something right
away I would say that it varies a lot
right now I feel pretty good about my
classical chess and I haven't played so
much rapid and blitz recently for so for
me it's really really hard to say I know
that I feel well about classical about
rapid and blitz I've usually been better
but I haven't played so much recently so
it's really hard to say but I look
forward to the challenge